The first step to becoming a polyglot
is to learn one more language.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here
and today I want to talk about
how to become a polyglot.
Now, remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
If you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a review.
I do appreciate it.
So how do we become polyglots?
Now the reason I'm talking about this is
because, um, my wife and I were playing
golf the other day at our golf club with
a couple, uh, probably in their sixties.
And often you, you know, you're, you're
teamed up with people you don't know, this
was our first chance to meet this couple.
And they told us they were going on
a bicycle trip with their friends,
eight couples going to Girona in Spain,
uh, to bicycle around in Catalonia.
So I said, are you going to
learn Catalan or Spanish?
Of course, I was going
to push LingQ, you know.
So, which I did of
course, but to no avail.
Uh, and so I said, are you gonna
learn Catalan or Spanish or Spanish?
And the answer was, well, I've heard
that you can get by with English.
All right, true enough.
Perhaps, maybe, maybe not.
I don't know.
In the city of Girona, uh, certainly
at the hotel and the restaurants you
can get by in the shops, but then,
um, outside of Girona I don't know.
I think if you're in a little town and
you get a flat tire and you're in trouble,
uh, maybe English is not so common.
I simply, I just don't know.
But for me, if I were going on a bicycle
trip to Catalonia, I would learn Catalan.
Now I speak Spanish, but so I
have the mentality of a polyglot
to me that would be fun.
Fun to explore Catalan, if I
learned Catalan, I would read
books about Catalonia in Catalan.
I would speak to people in Catalan.
I, that gives me a
great sense of pleasure.
I, I feel that I'm enriching my life by
learning another language, connecting
with people in their language.
I have the mentality of a polyglot.
Uh, I tweeted about this and I called this
the English language disease, that English
speakers, they have the option, or they
think they have the option of not learning
the language because we can get by.
And most of the responses to my
tweet, we're very much in agreement.
Gee, that's too bad, blah, blah, blah.
But one fellow from England,
or maybe he was somewhere else.
But his, his description showed that
he's from Manchester, he says where I
live, there was just a Portuguese person
showing a Danish person around our
compound and they were speaking English.
That's just the reality.
That's how it works.
Too bad.
So that person also doesn't have
the mentality of a polyglot.
So number one, to become a polyglot,
you have to want to become a polyglot.
You have to like speaking languages,
not just one, but several.
So that is a mindset.
Okay.
The second thing is, you know, I
didn't set out to become a polyglot.
I had not really heard the
term polyglot in English.
To me, a linguist was someone who
spoke several languages, but I also
didn't set out to become a linguist.
I got interested in French.
And then I had the opportunity to
learn Mandarin and then I was in
Japan, so I learned Japanese on my own.
And stepping back when I was in
France, I would hitchhike around
in Europe and I would always try
to speak uh, the local language.
So I think what I find, what I think
is useful to note there is that the
first step to becoming a polyglot
is to learn one more language.
Okay.
Because for people who have never really
acquired fluency in another language,
who have never converted themselves
into a fluent speaker of another
language, they don't have that feeling.
So the...
you can't, sort of skip past
the stage of learning one
language to become a polyglot.
You learn one language.
You now feel confident that
you can learn languages.
You enjoy the process, or maybe you don't.
Um, I think if you're doing it
the right way, you can enjoy it.
And then what happened to me
and I think what would happen
to a lot of people is you...
"gee, I learned one language.
Now I'd like to learn another language."
Because the experience of speaking
another language, of connecting with
people in their language is so rewarding
that we want to do it again and again,
and that sense of satisfaction that
actually we were able to succeed
in, in this task, which is not such
an easy task, uh, but that sense of
satisfaction makes us want to do it again.
Now, another thing about
becoming a polyglot, in my
opinion, we shouldn't be afraid.
Obviously, when we go from language
now B to language C and then
language D that means that we
aren't spending time on language B.
So we're leaving language B
because I firmly believe we
never master another language.
We can always improve
in that other language.
And yet we make the decision, I'm
not going to become even better.
Let's say my best foreign
language is French.
So I'm not going to become
even better in French.
Or let's say that the
next language is Japanese.
And I know there are great
gaps in my Japanese learning.
Okay.
I'm not going to work on
becoming even better in Japanese.
I'm going to go and
explore a new language.
So there's a choice there.
You sacrifice sort of what I would
consider the futile pursuit of perfection.
Now other people can disagree and they
want to pursue perfection, that's fine.
I'm not sort of making any value
judgements, but I think to be a
polygloy, it's different than trying
to become perfect in one language.
So we accept the fact that we're
going to not be as good in some of
the languages that we have learned.
We even accept the fact that there's going
to be interference, not only from our
own language, which is always the case,
but there's going to be interference from
these languages that we have learned in
the new languages that we are trying to
learn, because I find myself sometimes
when I'm searching for words in Russian
the other day I hadn't spoken Russian for
a long time and I was speaking Russian I'm
searching for words and up comes Persian.
So the more languages you have
in your head bouncing around as
your brain is going down different
pathways to find words there greater
likelihood is that it's going to go
into some rabbit hole, as they say.
Uh, where you're into
an yet another language.
So I think part of becoming a
polyglot is accepting that you're
going to be less than perfect.
That means you're going
to speak with mistakes.
Your pronunciation may not be perfect,
but you have this, this, um, sense of
achievement and the, the, uh, intellectual
stimulus of discovering a new world
yet another new world with all of
the people, and as you learn another
language, then the people of that language
come alive, the history comes alive.
And so I think the secret to being a
polyglot is to be interested in many
different languages and cultures.
Um, it may be that some people are
motivated to learn languages in order
to demonstrate that they they're
able to learn languages and, and you
know, like another notch on my belt.
I only had eight
languages now I have nine.
And that can also be a valid, um,
you know, motivation for becoming
a polyglot, just to demonstrate
your prowess at learning languages.
Uh, I wonder if that can sustain
you though, because if all
you want to do is show off.
Look, I can say a few things
in this other language.
That doesn't take a lot of, of
time and effort and you can get to
where you can say hello, how are
you in many different languages.
And, uh, that too is fun.
I'm not criticizing that, but in so
far as my own motivation as a polyglot,
if you look at my experience, not
with Persian and Arabic, which are
my 19th and 20th languages, I've
been at them for more than two years.
It's not a, it's not like three months.
And, uh, I'm continuing to
discover new things about those
languages in those cultures.
And I do want to get back to Turkish
and I hear that we have, we may have
our LingQ mini stories done up in Urdu,
in which case, once we get LingQ 5.0
launched, we will add Urdu and then
I would like to get into Urdu as my
approach into the south Asian languages,
because then because I'm a bit lazy at
learning new writing systems, then I
won't have to, you know, learn either
Hindi or Punjabi writing systems.
And I'll still be able to get some sense
of the sounds of, of those languages.
I may still end up learning
the writing system, we'll see.
But you know this again, as a
polyglot, I have this tremendous
world of languages to look forward
to, and I don't know which languages
I'm going to explore in the future.
Uh, I think we'll have Tagalog.
We'll have Vietnamese at LingQ.
Thai, maybe, uh, maybe Indonesian,
maybe Swahili something
on the African continent.
I don't know.
But as a polyglot, my motivation
is to get in there and explore
these, but I recognize that each
and every one of them is going to
be a lot of work, uh, but enjoyable.
And, but for me, that's fine.
That's what I have to look forward to.
So perhaps that's my perspective
on how to become a polyglot.
But to summarize, you have to
be motivated to learn languages.
You have to be interested
in learning these languages.
in a particular language.
You learn them one at a time.
And as you achieve success in one
language, you may find that you're
motivated to learn another language.
You have to be unafraid of
interference from languages that
you have previously learned.
You have to be unafraid of the
fact that some of the languages
that you have learned will
actually get very, very rusty.
You may in fact, not be able
to speak in that language.
Like if you were to ask me now
to speak in Romanian or Greek, I
would, I wouldn't be able to do it.
And yet I know that I have learned
those languages to a level where I
went to the country and I was able to
communicate and that's okay because I
can't, you know, if you have 20 pots
on a stove, it's very difficult to keep
them all, you know, simmering without
burning any one of them or without
the fire going out here and there.
So that's fine.
So all of those things, I think, uh, are
part of the, the, um, you know, at least
in my case, the attitude of a polyglot,
I can't speak for other polyglots.
So there you have it.
How to become a polyglot.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Thank you for listening.
Bye.